[Music]
are you ready for this
try not to cry challenge Christmas is
the time for presents family and lots of
food every child has sent a letter to
Santa at least once in their lives but
while most kids wish for new toys and
Technology others wishes are much more
heartbreaking give this video a thumbs
up and don't forget to let us know if
you won the challenge at the end let's
check out the stories of kids whose
Christmas wishes left
Santa in tears Paul Trench imagine
discovering an old letter to Santa 50
years
after your loved one passed away it's an
emotional time especially if the death
of your loved one was never properly
explained that's exactly what happened
to ray trench who found a Christmas list
hidden back in 1966 just a few weeks
before his brother lost his life due to
an infection Paul was just 9 years old
when he wrote this letter that broke his
brother's heart his death was never
properly explained and was noted as an
unidentified viral infection but raised
memories came flooding back after he
discovered the Christmas letter in an
encyclopedia his list includes the
tabletop football game a torch and toy
cars ray noticed that he felt like he
was opening a time capsule and memories
of his childhood came flooding back he
also noted that he found the very first
draft of the Christmas letter which
included a different version of the
group tabletop game but later changed it
to the England vs. Argentina match
unfortunately Paul's letter didn't
manage to reach Santa until 50 years
later and Ray never got to enjoy the
table football game and have his
favorite team win the World Cup and
although Paul never got his Christmas
wish we have a feeling his letter was
better than any Christmas present for
his brother ray a nine year old boy most
kids want a new bike the latest game an
iPad or any other piece of technology
but it's those wishes that make us
realize just how privileged we are
hundreds of thousands of kids around the
world never get to play their favorite
games in fact their Christmas wishes are
much more heartbreaking all we know
about this little boy is that he's nine
years old his Christmas letter was sent
to an organization that provides
presents for kids each Christmas the
little boy was asked to put only five
things he wished for Christmas but guess
what he only put in two and you won't
believe what they are his identity is
unknown to the public but his message
will break your heart his two Christmas
wishes included new shoes and a happier
life that's it it really does make you
wonder what he's going through and how
many children are going through the
exact same thing and no one knows about
it so next time you get upset if you
didn't get your wanted Christmas present
remember this sweet nine year old boy
who just wanted new shoes and a happier
life the heartbreaking letter was posted
on Facebook where hundreds of people
have reached out and volunteered to help
the boy have the best Christmas ever
Lewis Williams we hope you have your box
of tissues ready because this one is
going to make you cry
Lewis Williams is a nine-year-old boy
who has a shiny face and an adorable
smile but unlike most kids Lewis's life
wasn't exactly easy and he broke
everyone's heart with his Christmas wish
most children ask for multiple things
and some even count them to make sure
they got the right amount on Christmas
Day we're looking at you Dudley Dursley
on his birthday
luckily Lewis Williams is nothing like
Dudley in fact his Christmas wish is so
heartbreaking it will remind us how
lucky we are for the things we do have
in our lives
Lewis comes from a very poor family who
became homeless after his mom struggled
to pay rent despite working two jobs as
a trainee teacher and having her own
business the family moved 14 times his
mom's heart broke when she found out
Lewis's Christmas letter where he said
that all he wanted was a forever home
where he could play with Legos all day
in his letter he said he doesn't need
new toys instead II once a place for his
old toys in a forever home he also
mentions that everyone is sad living
where they are and he wants his family
to be happy again
we hope that Luis will get his wish as
quickly as possible
Luke Bedford sometimes kids might
surprise us with their Christmas wishes
in eight-year-old Luke's case his
Christmas wish wasn't even for himself
Luke's letter to Santa started off with
dear mrs. Claus and mr. Claus aka Santa
in his letter
Luke explains that he doesn't want
presents and that the only thing he
wants for Christmas is money for charity
it turns out that his best friend Thomas
told him about his cousin Orla who is
suffering from cancer he says that he's
not sure what it is but that he knows
it's very bad he ends the letter with
saying please please please give me no
presents for Christmas his touching
letter moved his mother and his friends
cousins mother to tears
- what's even more fascinating is the
fact that Luka never even met Orla in
the first place
we bet that this Christmas letter left
Santa in tears because it definitely
left us but we're not done yet stay
tuned to hear about a heartbreaking
letter that was tied to a balloon Phoebe
vine although Christmas is a very
traditional holiday it can be changed
every year as people get older you might
find yourself celebrating the holiday
differently and sometimes you might find
yourself missing the people you love the
most
the seven-year-old Phoebe vine had to
experience that in one of the hardest
ways possible at the age of seven she
our mother in a heartbreaking story her
mother passed away from a highly
aggressive brain tumor just a year
before Phoebe sent a Christmas letter to
Santa asking him not to let her mother
died a year later she sent another
letter which will be turned in an
impactful message her Christmas message
to her mother which says dear mummy I
miss you so much this Christmas love you
forever Phoebe will be displayed at
London Underground station throughout
the holidays Phoebe said that she misses
her mother and that she wants to make
her proud of her daughter we're pretty
sure her mother will be extra proud of
her seven-year-old daughter who was able
to make such an impact during Christmas
if you're spending your Christmas
without your loved ones this year we're
sending you big Internet hugs and a lot
of love Spencer every Christmas Jim
glove and Dylan Parker accidentally
received hundreds of Christmas letters
to their New York address the 22nd
Street in Manhattan their residents
became known as st. Nick's but nobody's
sure how that happened in the first
place and every single year the couple
takes their time and make sure they
reply to every single Christmas letter
the requests range from new technology
to many simple things like a new coat
for Mom
Spencer one of the kids whose
heartbreaking letters I've delivered to
22nd Street ask for new socks that will
keep his feet warm a couple of people
even got suspicious of the legitimacy of
Jim and Dillon story and one lady waited
patiently outside of their apartment
until she saw kids run to catch the
postman sounds like a story right from a
movie in fact it will get turned into a
movie called The Miracle on 22nd Street
while the living situations of kids like
Spencer don't get explained the
heartbreaking letters make the couple
cry and even though the two no longer
live at the address they continue to
make sure that every child receives a
response to their Christmas letter
unknown child if you've managed to leave
a dry eye all this time this story might
completely break you this Christmas
letter was found tied to a balloon and
nobody was able to track the child who
sent it it was found by a man who was
hoping to track him down in order to buy
him some
miss presents the reason in his
heartbreaking letter which was dated on
December 1st 2016 the boy says he is
missing his father he says that he knows
he's in heaven but asks whether he's
seen he continues saying that he's back
in foster care because mom is sick and
that everything he wants for Christmas
is for his dad to put a note he wrote
himself under his pillow we're not
crying you are we have to admit that out
of all stories this one touched us the
most and we really hope this boy has
been found and that the man who found
the balloon was able to send him the
best Christmas present ever the image of
this letter has been posted and shared
on social media and foster agencies and
although it has touched a lot of people
the child hasn't been yet identified the
man who found the letter also said that
he'd like to set up a charity page to
buy Christmas presents for children
living in foster care
Ryan suffered we hope these stories were
a good lesson in appreciating what we
have Ryan suffers Christmas letter is
just as heartbreaking as any others
we've shared today Ryan was asked to
write his letter early but his mother
never expected he'll write something
like this like every child Brian first
asked for toys he wanted a
remote-control car and helicopter but
later changed it he says he doesn't want
those things anymore and instead he lets
a nick know that his sister amber is
still getting bullied and that it's not
fair he also says that he prayed that
they will stop but since God is always
busy
he needs Santa's help his mother's eyes
welled with tears as she read her son's
letter she was also aware that her
daughter was bullied but not to the
extent described by her son his mother
said that she hopes her son's runner
will bring more awareness to school
bullying and just how much it affects
everyone every single day at the end of
his letter Ryan as a PS saying that his
mom throws the best birthday parties and
Santa can come if he wants what a sweet
unselfish
Billy Caldwell if you made it this far
get ready because you're about to well
up Billy Caldwell is the 11-year old boy
he wrote his Christmas letter on a
hospital bed and his words are
absolutely heartbreaking in his letter
Billy asks taffet's take away his
seizures he suffers from an
uncontrollable epilepsy and is in a u.s.
hospital for treatment that's not
available in his own country in his
letter he also says that he doesn't want
to go and live with the angels instead
he wants to stay with his mom and his
big brother at the age of 2 years Billy
was already given little chance of
surviving however he's still fighting
nine years on his mother was told that
his seizures were in too deep to be
removed by laser surgery but it seems
like Santa listened to his wishes his
letter was sent in 2016 and one year
later his chance of surviving became
much bigger we're not sure whether it
was Santa who made his wish come true or
not but Billy was able to get better
with medical marijuana he's also the
first person in the UK who ever received
a medical prescription for marijuana and
according to his family is precisely
what helped Billy survive and fight on
his horrifying illness his story is
definitely one of the most heartbreaking
and inspirational Christmas stories of
all time that's it for our video for
more videos like this one check out 15
hidden images and logos you never notice
see you next time
[Music]